The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we want to
discuss line shifts and line
broadening.
And I assume you'll
remember that last class we
did some brainstorming and came
up with quite a number of line
broadening and line shifts
mechanism, temporal lifetime
broadening, motional
broadening, external field
broadening,
collisional broadening.
And as I indicated at
the end of last class,
those different
broadening mechanism
have much more in common
than you may think.
And you will see that they
have much more in common
when we look at it from
the fundamental perspective
of coherence.
Any line broadening
mechanism comes
because the atom experience, the
environment and the drive field
as a coherent source only
for limited coherence time.
So the concept of
the coherence time
will actually provide
a common denominator
for all those line
broadening mechanisms.
However, before I
present to you this kind
of correlation function approach
to what's line broadening,
I think it's really
important that we
go through some simple cases.
I always want you to learn
phenomena in the simplest
possible manifestation,
in a situation where
without any math you
see what's going on.
And what I particularly
love is if there
is an analytic solution
where everything
is sort of transparent here.
So therefore, before we discuss
in a comprehensive way line
shifts and line
broadening, I want
to go through simple cases.
Now, I decided for this class
that most of today's lecture
uses pre-written slides
because those cases are
so simple that I would be
almost afraid I would bore you
if I would write it out.
Because if you look at
this equation in one second
you get it, and it takes me
10 or 20 seconds to write it.
On the other hand,
I would sort of
give the responsibility to you.
If I'm flooding you with
too much information,
ask me questions,
slow me down, or say,
can you please go over that?
So I don't want
to obscure things
by going through them faster.
I also looked a
little bit forward
to the end of the course.
We are about OK with the
pace of the course, or maybe
one hour behind.
And so in order to make room for
discussions of superradiance,
which I would like to have
with you in a couple of weeks,
I thought I can save
half an hour here
by going over that material
a little bit faster.
But these are really
just illustrations
of line broadening.
And you should actually
know most of them already.
So the first cases are
actually leading you up
to the Ramsey
resonance, to the method
of separated oscillatory fields,
which is really absolutely
important for high
resolution spectroscopy.
But before we can fully
understand the Ramsey
resonance, we have to
understand the Rabi resonance.
So what I've written
down here is for you
just the well-known formula
for Rabi oscillations.
And if you now simply assume
we let the atoms interact
with the field by a fixed
amount time tau in such a way
that we have a pi pulse,
then this probability
as a function of detuning
becomes a line shape.
And this line shape
is plotted here.
It has a full width
of half maximum,
which is approximately 1/tau.
And this is-- you can
regard it as the Fourier
limit of finite interaction
time broadening.
We are observing the
atoms for time tau
and the line which is
on the order of 1/tau.
But we also know
from the Rabi formula
that we have these side lobes,
so we see some oscillatory line
shape.
OK, now, with the
advent of trapped atoms,
you can often have
the situation that you
have an ensemble
of trapped atoms.
You flash on your drive field
for fixed amount time tau.
At least for most of last
century, this was not possible.
You had atomic beams.
And in an atomic
beam, what is fixed
is not the interaction time tau
but the interaction length l.
And then due to the
velocity distribution,
different velocity
groups of atoms
interact a different
amount of time with that.
So for conceptional reasons but
also for the historic context,
you should sort of have an idea
what the Rabi apparatus is.
I may have mentioned
it, but I regard Rabi
as sort of one of my
ancestors in my family tree
because Rabi was the PhD
advisor of Norman Ramsey, who
was the PhD advisor
of Dan Kleppner, who
of Dave Pritchard.
And Dave Pritchard was
my postdoctoral mentor.
So I'm really talking here
about my scientific great-great
grandfather.
Anyway, so the famous Rabi
apparatus is the following.
You use one Stern-Gerlach magnet
to prepare a certain hyperfine
state.
Then you have the
interaction region,
and this is what
we are focusing on.
And then later, if a spin
flip has taken place,
you can figure that
out by running it
through a
Stern-Gerlach analyzer.
So it's this ABC
region, and we are
talking about this middle region
where we have an interaction
time which is now given by the
length divided by the velocity.
So what we have to
do is-- well, that's
why I'm saying
it's simple cases,
and I hope I can
go fast-- you just
take the previous result
with a Rabi probability
and convolute it with a
velocity distribution.
So when we do that,
we find two effects.
One is, well, due to the
velocity distribution,
the line width becomes
a factor of 2 broader,
but it's still
proportional to something
on the order of unity divided
by the interaction time.
And because the
different velocity groups
have a different
kind of oscillations
as a function of detuning,
the oscillatory behavior
now disappears because
it becomes averaged out
[? of ?] the velocity groups.
OK so this is the Rabi
method or the Rabi resonance,
where we have one interaction
pulse or one interaction
time for an atom.
The next method is now
what was introduced
by Norman Ramsey as the method
of separate oscillatory fields.
And for that and
other contributions
he was awarded the
Nobel Prize in 1990.
And the difference
is the following.
In the Rabi method, we
let the atoms interact
with the drive field for fixed
lengths l or fixed time tau.
But in the Ramsey
method, we interrogate,
we drive the atoms
with two short pulses,
which are separated.
So in the simplest
case, we do 2 pi
over 2 pulses
separated by a time t.
And now, if you have two
pulses, everything is coherent.
The two pulses can
interfere constructively
or destructively.
So what you would
expect is that-- I
want to give you two pictures.
One is the Bloch sphere
picture, but let's just sort
of play with the
concept of interference.
If this is zero
detuning, the two pulses
are separated by a time t.
And therefore, you
would now observe,
as a function of detuning,
Ramsey fringes and oscillatory
behavior, which
has a spacing which
is 2 pi over the
time between pulses.
The envelope of
the whole fringes
is related to the short
time of the duration.
It's like a double
slit experiment.
You know, each slit is
broad, and the width here
is given by 1 over the short
time delta t of the pulse.
But then the two
slits interfere.
And the interference
pattern is the distance
between the slits, which
now in the temporal domain
is the time capital
T between them.
So these are sort of
typical Ramsey fringes.
And now, if you would
average over a broad velocity
distribution, then
you would kind of
average-- you would maybe
see one or two side lobes,
but the other fringes
are averaged out.
So the central peak,
the resolution is again
on the order of 1/T.
It's the total time
of the experiment,
which is setting
the ultimate resolution,
similar to the Rabi resonance.
So this uses the
picture of interference
between two pulses.
But I also want to
sort of give you
the Bloch sphere picture,
because it's beautiful.
For that I need a
little bit of room.
So an atom enters the
first Ramsey region,
and it has to spin down.
You do a pi/2 pulse,
which is at 90 degrees.
And now what happens is
there is a field-free region
between the two pulses,
so the atom is now
precessing at its
resonance frequency.
OK, but the synthesizer which
is attached to your coils
is also sort of precessing
at this frequency.
And when you add zero detuning,
the synthesizer and the atoms
are aligned again.
And the second pi/2 pulse
is now flipping the atoms,
and you've 100% excitation.
And this is what you see here.
But now let's assume you
are slightly detuned.
Then the atom is precessing,
and your synthesizer
is precessing at a slightly
different frequency.
And now in the second
region, the frequency
of the synthesizer
may be different
with-- the phase
of the synthesizer
is 180 degree different
from the phase of the atom.
And then instead of flipping
the atoms up and getting 100%
in the up state, the
atom is now flipped down.
And this explains
the first minimum.
So you should really see
that in this long region,
nothing happens.
But you accrue a relative
phase between the synthesizer
and the atom, which oscillates
at its resonance frequency.
So based on this model,
you could work out
mathematically every aspect of
those fringes I've shown you.
But I decided to take the
equations out of the lecture
and just present you with
this physical picture.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: If you have a
velocity distribution,
would the points of
those minimums change
or is it still this--
PROFESSOR: Well, good question.
The spacing is the time T.
But if you have a velocity
distribution, let's say a
velocity distribution which
has a width delta v over v
of 30%, what we have kept
fixed in the beam
experiment are the lengths,
the interaction lengths.
So time is length over velocity.
So therefore, when
the velocity changes
by plus/minus 30% in
your atomic beam--
unless you take a
supersonic beam with a very
narrow velocity
distribution-- then that
means one velocity class
has this set of fringes.
The other velocity class has
this similar set of fringes,
but like in a
harmonica, everything
is now spread out by 30%.
And if you have now 30%
velocity resolution,
that means you may be able
to see two or three fringes.
But the central fringe is sort
of like a white light fringe.
There is no relative
phase shift.
And therefore all the
different velocity classes
will have a maximum
at zero detuning.
So in the extreme limit
of a very broad velocity
distribution, the only
feature which survives
is the central fringe.
But this is where you obtain
your spectroscopic information
from.
Will?
AUDIENCE: You have explained
this Bloch sphere picture
assuming unbroken coherence
between your synthesizer
and the field-free
evolution of your atom?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it equivalent
to if you wrote down the time
evolution operator, you
would say that there's 0 Rabi
frequency, but no
detuning in your field?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what if
I-- is this necessary,
to have this unbroken coherence
if I unplug my synthesizer
and plug in a new
one [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Yes, you
can do spectroscopy
with a resolution
delta mu, which is 1/T,
only if you have a synthesizer
which has a frequency
stability which is
better than 1/T.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Otherwise, we've
done this a little bit
when we talk narrowband
and broadband.
When we talked about
narrowband and broadband cases,
you are always limited
in your resolution
by whatever is broader.
Here I'm discussing about the
width of the atomic system,
assuming a perfect synthesizer.
But then in essence, you
should convolute this result
with the spectral distribution
of your synthesizer.
And then if the synthesizer
has a resolution which
is worse than that, you would
actually blur out the fringes
through the convolution
with the frequency
spectrum of the synthesizer.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: So that also means
if you add a [INAUDIBLE]
to the second coil, [INAUDIBLE]
just like if you had
[INAUDIBLE] to one of the--
PROFESSOR: Yes, actually,
if you would add a pi phase
shift to the second
coil, then the minimum--
the central feature would
not be maximum or minimal.
Yes.
And that's why when you have
atomic clocks with a beam,
the question of
distributed phase
shifts within the microwave
cavity play a big role.
And this is related
to are the two Ramsey
zones really at the
same phase or not?
So that's an important
issue for ultimately making
resolution spectroscopy.
OK.
Since-- OK.
So we've discussed
two methods now,
the Ramsey method
versus the Rabi method.
And let me discuss advantages
or disadvantages of the method.
So if you're an atomic
physicist and you
have to give advice
to your friends
whether they should use the
Ramsey or the Rabi method,
these are your talking points.
So one point is that I said the
central feature of the Ramsey
fringes is 1/T. The
Rabi feature is 1/T,
so we are both limited
by time resolution,
because this is a Fourier limit.
But if you work out
the details, you
find that the Ramsey fringe
is about 2 times narrower
than the Rabi resonance.
Just how things work
out mathematically--
I can't give you any
real deeper insight why.
It just works out to be a factor
of 2 narrower than the Rabi
resonance.
There's one important aspect,
and this is the following.
When you accrue the
spectroscopic information,
you compare-- I hope you
remember my demonstration-- you
compare the atomic oscillator
to the synthesizer,
but you're not interacting
with each other.
So therefore you don't
have any power broadening.
You're comparing the free
evolution of the atom
with the propagating
phase in your synthesizer.
And therefore, your Rabi signal
has no power broadening at all.
And that means that,
however, the Rabi signal,
at least for small detunings
which are smaller than the Rabi
frequency, will always depend
quadratically on delta.
Remember, generalized
Rabi frequency,
you add or make a Rabi
squared and detuning
squared in quadrature.
So therefore you will
always get effects
for small detunings
which are quadratic,
whereas the way how you set
up the Ramsey experiment, you
can explore a linear dependence.
So you have more
sensitivity here.
Finally-- well, not finally.
There are more.
Next is the Ramsey spectroscopy.
It's done in a
field-free region,
so you're not
driving the system.
You observe the free evolution.
Therefore you have no AC Stark
effects due to the drive field.
Of course, you drive the
system in the two Ramsey zones.
And some form of AC Stark
effect may come in in the way
that you may not
have exactly a pi
pulse due to AC Stark effects.
But this is sort of a
higher order effect.
The basic spectroscopy
is done by comparing
the atomic oscillator with
the frequency synthesizer.
Since it's a field-free
region, this region can now
be used for-- well,
let me say generally
for experimental additions.
And of course, what should
immediately come to your mind
is the Nobel-Prize-winning
experiments
of Serge Haroche where
he had two Ramsey
regions with microwaves.
And in between in the
field-free region,
the atom passed
through another cavity.
And in between the
Ramsey zones, the atom
experienced a phase
shift due to the presence
of a single photon.
So the field-free
region could now
be used to put in a cavity
which was filled with one or two
photons.
And the atom was in a
non-destructive way reading out
how many photons were there.
So this is another advantage
of the Ramsey spectroscopy,
that you can now use
the field-free region
to measure something.
You can introduce a phase
shift, which can then
be read out through the
Ramsey interference.
Similarly, if you just think of
how the resonance comes along,
if you had a slightly
fluctuating magnetic field
between the two
Ramsey regions, this
would not necessarily
broaden your signal.
Because what you measure is
the integrated phase evolution
of the atomic oscillator.
So in other words, what you
get is shift of the resonance,
which is the average over the
inhomogeneous magnetic field.
Whereas when you do
a Rabi resonance,
whenever you have a
field inhomogeneity,
you broaden and shift the
resonance to this field value.
So in other words,
the Ramsey resonance
depends only on the average
along the mean energy
separation between
the two levels.
And therefore
inhomogeneous fluctuations,
spatial fluctuations, can
completely average out.
Whereas in the Rabi method,
any kind of fluctuations
leads to line broadening.
And finally, I will explain
that in more detail later on.
But what happens in
the Ramsey method
if the separation
between the two regions
is much longer than the
spontaneous lifetime of one
of the levels?
Do you now get a
resolution which
is 1/T, the temporal separation
between the two interrogations?
Or do you get a
resolution which is 1/tau,
the lifetime of
the excited level?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: 1/tau.
PROFESSOR: It would be
a good clicker question.
So who thinks it's 1/tau?
Who thinks it's 1/T?
So who thinks it's
limited by lifetime?
Who thinks it's limited
by the interrogation time?
OK.
So that's a minority
for the Ramsey method.
The minority is correct.
And the picture
you should have is
that you remember the sort of
picture of those oscillators.
But if some atoms decay away,
it diminishes your signal.
But the interference comes
only from the survivors.
And the survivors have survived
in the exponential tail
of the natural decay, but
they are longer lived.
And therefore, you can
actually do spectroscopy
which is narrower than
the natural line width,
using Ramsey spectroscopy.
But if you do Rabi
spectroscopy, you're
limited by the
spontaneous lifetime.
And this is probably what was
in mind of the other people who
raised their hand
for option A. But why
there is a difference
between the Rabi
and the Ramsey method,
that's something
I want to discuss later.
OK, so Ramsey has
the possibility,
sub-natural line
width is possible
when the interaction
time is larger
than the inverse
natural line width.
OK.
Questions about Ramsey method?
Good.
Physics Today has a wonderful
article written by Ramsey
which was reprinted
recently, I think
on the occasion of his death.
I will post this
article to our website.
Then you can really
read about it
in the language
of Norman Ramsey.
OK, let's move on.
I said we are discussing
simple examples.
So we have discussed the example
of Rabi resonance and Ramsey
resonance.
Now I want to talk about line
shape with exponential decay.
One reason why I
wanted to give you
a simple model for
exponential decay
because in the end,
everything is exponentially
decaying because of the
finite lifetime of levels.
And with this very,
very simple model,
I want to convey to you that
not all exponential decays are
equal.
You have to be a
little bit careful.
And this is just sort
of the simplest example.
And you learn something
by figuring out
what is different from
spontaneous decay here
and what are the
consequences of that.
So remember where we are.
We have the Rabi resonance.
I gave you the simple example
that the Rabi resonance
is applied for fixed time tau.
And then we did one extension
we averaged over the velocity
distribution.
But now we can just say, OK, we
have our Rabi resonance here.
But we assume that
while we drive the atom,
they decay away.
If you want, you can think
these are radioactive atoms
and they decay
[? radioactively. ?]
For that situation,
this model is exact.
So therefore, instead of having
a fixed interaction time tau,
you have a distribution, which
is an exponential distribution.
So all we have to do is we
have to take our result, which
I discussed 10 or 20 minutes
ago, with the fixed interaction
time and convolute it with
the distribution of times
the atom experiences
the drive field.
And what I've introduced here
is the exponential is gamma.
And the mean interaction time
over which an atom interacts
with the drive field
is just 1 over gamma,
and I called that tau.
So now we had the
Rabi probability here,
but now we convolute it
with the distribution
of interaction times.
And this is now the probability
that after the Rabi pulse
the spin was moved from
spin down to spin up.
Or if you have an
electronic transition,
from ground to excited state.
So this integral can
be analytically solved.
That's why it's
worth presenting.
And what you get is a
Lorentzian line shape.
And this Lorentzian
line shape shows
power broadening, which
actually you should find nice,
because we will
sometimes [INAUDIBLE]
in power broadening you can't
get out of perturbation theory.
And a lot what we have
done and what I actually
want to do for the remainder of
this chapter on line broadening
is a perturbative approach.
So that's another reason I
want to present it to you here.
These are some
non-perturbative results,
and they show the physics of
power broadening, saturation
broadening.
But there are two things
which are noteworthy.
One is the full
width at half maximum
is not gamma but 2 gamma.
So if we had natural
decay at a rate gamma,
the Lorentzian which we
get is only half as wide.
But you can
immediately say, well,
that can be understood because
here I assumed the atoms just
decay away no matter whether
they are in the ground
or in the excited state.
And I gave you a model that
you assume there is maybe
radioactive decay independent
of the internal state.
And now you can wave
your hands and say, OK,
if you have only decay
in the excited state
and not in the
ground state, this
should give you a factor
of 2 in the width.
And this may explain why we have
a full width of half maximum
here of 2 gamma and in
spontaneous decay it is gamma.
But there's another thing
which is interesting, maybe
more interesting.
And this is the
power broadening.
If you take the power-broadened
Lorentzian line width
and we look at it in
the limit of high power,
it is 2 times the
Rabi frequency.
Well, if we have a system
which has spontaneous decay
and we would go to
the high power limit--
we've discussed it before.
What you get is square root
2 of the Rabi frequency.
So the message I
can give you here
is that saturation
broadening, power broadening
depends sensitively on the
exact nature of the decay
and of the lifetime
broadening involved.
And if you really
want to do it right,
you have to use the
optical Bloch equations.
So let me just write that down.
So what we learned from that is,
yes, we get power broadening.
We have a simple model
for power broadening here.
But power broadening
depends sensitively
on the nature of
the decay process.
And so if you want to get this
result without any assumptions
or approximations, you
should use the optical Bloch
equations.
And yes, your
homework assignment
looked at the optical
Bloch equations.
And I think you also found
out that some results
for the optical Bloch
equations really
depend on the ratio of gamma
1 gamma 2 or T1 and T2.
So that is with a more
mathematical formalism
shows you that the way
how you introduce decay
into the atomic system, it's not
just there is one time constant
and the result just depends
on the time constant.
There are some subtleties.
Questions about that?
OK.
Now-- and many people
have asked me about it--
I think for the first
time in this course
we bring in motion of the atoms.
So the atoms are now not
pinned down at the origin.
Maybe you can imagine
you have an atom which
is held in a solid state
lattice with a nanometer,
and we just look at
the internal structure.
We have maybe some ions
implanted into a material.
And these ions are fluorescent,
and we are probing them.
Or we're doing spin
flip on nuclei,
which are nuclei of atoms which
are part of a condensed metal
lattice.
Or if you want to think
more [? with ?] the methods
of atomic physics, you have the
most tightly confining ion trap
in the world.
You are deeply in
the Lamb-Dicke limit,
and your ion just cannot move.
It's always in the ground
state of the ion trap,
and all you are dealing with is
the internal degree of freedom.
Actually, let me make a comment.
I often see when people
approach me and ask
me question that they
are not necessarily
making the separation.
When they think
about what happens
to the internal
structure of atoms, what
is in their head is, but there
is motion, there is recoil.
You can, in my experience,
always separate the two.
You can create a
situation where you only
probe the internal
degree of freedom
by tightly confining
the atom, and then you
can relax the condition that
the atoms is tightly confined.
Now the atoms can
move, and then all
of the things we want to
discuss now come into play.
Sometimes people assume, yes,
but if you confine an atom,
doesn't the atom always have
a de Broglie wavelengths?
And isn't that
another length scale?
The answer is no,
because you need
a coupling between the internal
degree and the external degree,
or you need some way of exciting
the external degree of motion.
And if you have a tightly
confining ion trap,
h bar omega, the next vibration
or level in the ion trap
is so high, you may not excite
it with the recoil of a photon.
But there is another limit
which I often find very useful,
and this is the following.
When we talk about
spectroscopy, spin flips,
electronic transitions,
we have not really
talked about the
mass of the atom.
The mass of the nucleus only
appeared in the reduced mass.
Remember when we did last
class the hydrogen atom?
We had the reduced mass,
which was slightly different
from the electron mass.
So if you want to completely
exclude the motion of the atom,
just work in the limit that
the nucleus has infinite mass.
If the nucleus
has infinite mass,
its de Broglie wavelength is 0.
It's confined in a
harmonic oscillator
to sort of a delta function.
So by just assuming that
you deal with infinite mass,
you automatically neglect
all possible motions.
And as you will actually
see from the next formula,
working in the infinite mass
limit means that your Doppler
shift is 0, your recoil
shift is 0, everything is 0.
So either way,
I've given you now
two ways how I recommend
that you think about all
the physics we have
discussed which
deals with the internal
degree of freedom
by either saying the atom
is tightly organized.
But then some people
say, ah, but then
it has Heisenberg Uncertainty.
There's a lot of momentum.
It doesn't matter.
If it's localized,
it's localized.
But you can also assume just
the infinite mass limit.
And in both cases, the
result is you can completely
talk about so many aspects
of internal excitations
without even considering
what happens externally.
Any questions about that?
So now we take the mass from
infinity to finite value,
and now we want
to allow the atom
to move and have kinetic energy.
So let's start out very simple.
We have an atom which is
addressed in the excited state,
and it emits a photon.
Before the emission
of the photon,
the total energy is
the excitation energy.
But after the emission
of the photon,
the atom is in the ground state.
The photon has been emitted.
But now the atom, due to
the photon recoil h bar k,
has kinetic energy.
So therefore the frequency
of emission of the photon
does not happen at the
resonance frequency of the atom
because some part of
the electronic energy
goes into the kinetic energy
of the recoiling atom.
And this is called
the recoil shift.
We start at 0 velocity.
At 0 velocity, you don't
have any Doppler shift.
But you do have recoil shift.
Well, we can play the same game.
We have an atom addressed.
It absorbs the photon.
And after the atom has
absorbed the photon,
it's in the excited state.
But now you have
to excite the atom
if you want to transfer
the atom to the excited
state with a frequency
which is slightly
higher than the
resonance frequency.
Because the laser has
to provide not only
the energy for the
electronic excitation
but also the energy for
the kinetic energy at which
the atom recoils.
So therefore we find that, due
to the recoil of the photon,
the absorption line
and the emission
line for an atom
addressed are shifted.
The shift is the
recoil energy, h bar--
the momentum of the photon
squared, divided by 2 times
the mass of the atom.
And the shifts are opposite
for absorption and emission.
So therefore, if you look at
the two processes for absorption
and emission, there is a recoil
splitting between the two.
This recoil splitting between
emission and absorption
is just a few kilohertz.
And it was really one of the
wonderful accomplishments
when high resolution
spectroscopy came along
and John Hall at
Boulder managed to have
lasers stabilized
to sub kilohertz.
For the first time, this recoil
splitting could be resolved.
So he had set up some
intracavity absorption,
and he saw sort of two peaks
in some kind of spectrum.
I don't remember the
details, but two peaks
split by a few
kilohertz were really
the hallmark of the photon
recoil shifting the lines away
from resonance.
OK, so now we know what the
kinetic energy of the atom
does.
If it emits a photon,
there is recoil.
But now, in addition, we
can drop the assumption
that the atom is initially at
rest when it absorbs or emits.
Now the atom is moving.
But for that, we don't
need any new concept.
Because the moving atom-- we
can just do a transformation
into the frame of the atom
where the atom is at rest.
And then just using the
relativistic transformation,
we are now transferring
the laser frequency
from the atomic frame
into the lab frame.
So what I've
written down here is
the general special
relativity formula
for the frequency shift.
And I've assumed that
the photon is emitted
at an angle phi with respect
to the motion of the atom.
So now we obtain-- OK, let me
do a second-order expansion.
Usually, our atoms
are non-relativistic,
so it's the first- and
second-order term which
are most important.
And if we are now
looking in the lab frame,
what is the frequency where
we emit and absorb photons.
It's a resonance frequency
minus/plus the recoil shift,
which we have already
discussed in isolation
by assuming we have
atoms at 0 velocity.
But now the velocity
of the atom leads
to a first-order and
second-order Doppler shift.
If v/c is small, what
is most important
is the first-order
Doppler shift.
And in almost all cases
[? where we ?] do spectroscopy,
dominant line
broadening effect comes
from the first-order shift.
However, let me point out
that the first-order shift can
be suppressed.
One simple way to suppress
it-- interrogate the atoms
at an angle of 90 degrees.
Have an atomic beam.
And if you interrogate them
with a laser beam at 90 degrees,
the cosine phi is 0.
k dot v is 0.
And this is the oldest method
to do Doppler-free spectroscopy.
In your new homework
assignment, you
will discuss saturation
spectroscopy.
If you have a broad
velocity distribution,
but you find a way of labeling
atoms with a certain velocity
class, then you have created
your own narrow velocity class
where the Doppler
broadening is absent
because you've only
one velocity class.
And these methods of nonlinear
spectroscopy, the concept
will be developed in
the homework assignment.
Finally-- and this will
be the next chapter
which we talk in class here
in about two weeks-- this
is by having two-photon
spectroscopy.
To give you the
appetizer, if you
have two photons from opposite
direction, the Doppler shifts.
One has a positive, one has
a negative Doppler shift.
And if you stack
up the two photons,
the sum of the two
Doppler shifts is 0.
So two-photon spectroscopy
provides you an opportunity
to completely eliminate
the Doppler shift.
However, no matter what you
pick here for the angle,
there is a part of the
second-order Doppler
shift you can never get rid of.
And this is something
important to keep in mind.
The second-order Doppler
shift, at least one part of it,
comes from the relativistic
transformation of time.
So if you have atoms moving
at different velocities,
time in the frame of the atom
ticks slightly differently
depending what the velocity is.
And therefore, if
you do spectroscopy,
you measure time
in the lab frame,
but the atoms measure time
in the resonance frequency
in their own frame.
Then there is
inevitably broadening.
So for instance, when people
did Ted Hansch's experiment,
the famous two-photon
spectroscopy
on hydrogen, high resolution,
determination of the Lamb
shift, the Rydberg constant--
one of the flagship experiments
of high resolution
laser spectroscopy.
A limit is the
second-order Doppler effect
because of its
relativistic nature.
And the only way to suppress
the relativistic Doppler effect
is by cooling the atoms,
reducing their velocity.
So let me just write that down.
So when we suppress
the first-order effect,
then the limit is given
by the second-order term.
And just repeat, the
second-order term cannot be
eliminated by playing
geometric tricks,
90-degree angles and such,
because it's fundamentally
rooted in the relativistic
definition of time.
OK.
Any questions about recoil
shifts, Doppler shifts?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What are
the correct way
to determine whether
we're in tightly confined
[? regime ?] or not?
PROFESSOR: OK, the
question is what
is the criteria on whether we
are tightly confined or not.
I will give a full answer
to that in about a week when
I discuss with you
in great detail
the spectrum of a
confined particle.
And what we will
introduce is it's
the frequency of
harmonic confinement.
And we have to
compare the frequency
of harmonic confinement
to two other relative,
to two other
important frequencies.
One frequency is the
recoil frequency.
And another one may be
the natural line width.
So in other words, when
we discuss the spectrum
of confined particles,
we can discuss it
as a function of three
parameters-- confinement
frequency, recoil frequency,
and natural line widths.
And based on the hierarchy
of those three frequencies,
we find limiting cases.
And we will find, then--
and this is probably
what you are aiming for-- at
some limit when you reduce
the confinement in your
harmonic oscillator,
you will actually retrieve
the free gas limit.
Or to be very brief,
confinement, you
have the benefit of confinement.
Confinement means the
motion of the atom
is quantized in
units of h bar omega.
So you shouldn't
think about velocity.
You should think
about discrete levels.
And I will show you that the
spectrum which is broadened
becomes a spectrum with
discrete levels and side bands.
As long as you can resolve the
side bands, you can see them,
you can actually
address the line
in the middle which has
no motion blurring at all.
But you have to resolve it.
So one condition here now is
that the harmonic oscillator
frequency is larger than
the natural broadening
of each line.
If the lines blur, you're
pretty much back to free space
and you've lost the
advantage of confinement.
But maybe we can discuss
some of those aspects
after I've introduced the line
shape of confined particles.
OK.
Let me now discuss
briefly, or use
what we have just discussed
about Doppler shift
to discuss the line
shape in a gas.
Well, of course, line
shapes in a gas--
that's what all people observed
when they did spectroscopy
before the advent of
trapping and cooling.
But even now, we
often have a situation
that we have a thermal clouded
microkelvin temperature.
And what we see is
still broadening
due to the thermal motion.
So therefore, let
me just tell you
a few aspects of that which
you might find interesting.
So one is when we have
an non-degenerate gas,
this is described by a
Boltzmann distribution, sort
of a Gaussian
distribution of velocity.
And therefore, if the
first-order Doppler shift
is relevant, the
is proportionate to v,
so therefore the spectrum
we observe is nothing else
than the spectrum in velocity
multiplied with a k vector.
The Doppler shift is k dot
v, and therefore the velocity
distribution by
multiplying it with k
is turned into a
frequency distribution.
And so the classic
frequency distribution
you would expect
in a gas is simply
the Gaussian distribution.
And the Doppler width,
the spectroscopic width,
is nothing else than whatever
the characteristic speed
in your Boltzmann
distribution is, typically
the most probable speed, 2 times
the temperature over the mass
multiplied with the k vector.
And in many cases, it is this
Doppler width which dominates.
I've just given you
typical examples here.
If you've stabilized your laser
to a room temperature vapor
cell, you will encounter
typical Doppler widths
on the order of 1 gigahertz.
This is 100 times larger than
the natural line width, which
is 100 times larger
than the recoil shift.
So that is the usual
hierarchy of shifts
and broadening mechanisms.
So therefore, you would
think that if the Gaussian
line widths due to the
velocity distribution is
100 times larger than the
natural line widths which
is described by Lorentzian,
you can completely
neglect the Lorentzian.
But that's not the
case, and that's
what I want to discuss now.
What happens is you
have a Gaussian which
is much, much broader.
But the Gaussian
decays exponentially,
whereas your narrow Lorentzian
decays with a power law.
So just to give you
the example, if you
go two full
half-line widths away
from the center of a
Gaussian, the Gaussian
has dropped to 0.2%.
The Lorentzian has still 6%.
So therefore, what
happens is if you
have your gigahertz
broadened line in a gas,
but you go further
and further away,
at some point what
you encounter are not
the Gaussian wings but
the Lorentzian wings.
And that's maybe also sort of
intellectually interesting.
I've talked to you about
homogeneous, inhomogeneous line
widths.
The bulk part of the
Gaussian is inhomogeneous
because you can talk
to different atoms
at different velocities.
Each atom resonates
with its own Lorentzian,
and it is inhomogeneously
broadened.
But in the line widths which
is due to the Lorentzian,
the homogeneous
broadening dominates.
And since the Lorentzian
has information
about either the
natural line widths
or in a gas about
collisional broadening,
you can actually, far away in
the wings of your line shape,
retrieve information about
collisional physics, which,
in the center of the
line, is completely
masked by the first-order
Doppler shift.
OK.
So I've already written it down.
So far wing spectroscopy
in the gas phase
can give you
interesting information
about atomic collisions
and atomic interactions.
So having started
out by telling you
that it's a first-order Doppler
shift which usually dominates,
but then telling you that if
you go far away from the line
center, the Lorentzian actually
dominates, that means now there
are situations where
we want actually both.
And the general
solution, of course,
is you do a convolution.
Each atom with a given
velocity has a Lorentzian.
And then you have to do the
convolution with the velocity
distribution.
So therefore, the general
situation for gas phase
spectroscopy is the
convolution of the Lorentzian
for each atom and the Gaussian
velocity distribution.
And since this was the standard
case which people encountered
when they did spectroscopy
in the gas phase,
this convoluted line
shape has its own name.
It's called the Voigt profile.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: It's not
obvious to me what exactly
about the atomic
collisions and interaction,
the wings of the
Lorentzian [INAUDIBLE].
Don't you just learn
about the bare line?
Like the un-Doppler
shifted line itself?
PROFESSOR: OK, that's a good
question, as it is not obvious.
And yes, the literature
is full of it.
Because if you don't have
Doppler-free spectroscopy,
if you are always limited
by the Doppler broadening,
put yourself back
into the last century.
But you really want
to learn something
about how atoms
interact and collide,
this was the way to do it.
I don't want to go
into many details
because it's a little
bit old fashioned.
We have other ways to do it now.
But I find it
intellectually interesting
when we talk about line shapes
to realize there are maybe
some subtleties we wouldn't have
thought about it by ourselves.
But just to give you one
example, for whatever reason,
you're very, very interested.
What is the rate of
collision of atoms?
Let's just assume the
simplest model for collisions
that when two atoms collide,
the excited state is de-excited.
Then the lifetime
of the excited state
is no longer 1 over
gamma, the lifetime
is the collision time defined
as a de-excitation time.
And you're really interested
for whatever reason,
because you have the world's
best theory on this object,
that you have a theory what is
the collision time for excited
sodium with argon,
with helium, kind
of with all different elements.
And you have an
interesting theory
which actually reflects how
sodium in the excited state
would interact with noble gases.
And you really want
to test your theory.
Well, now what happens is
the situation is simple.
You have a Lorentzian,
but the Lorentzian
has a broadening which
is the collision rate.
And by carefully analyzing the
wings of your Doppler profile,
you find the collision rate--
as a functional of buffer
gas density, as a function of
noble gas, whatever you pick.
That's one example.
Another example would
be, there may be also
somewhere nontrivial shifts
when the atoms collide.
We'll talk about it
also a little bit later.
The experience-- de-excitation
is one possibility.
But more subtle
things can happen.
For instance, just a
phase perturbation,
or when atoms come
close to each other,
they feel the electric field.
And the electric field
causes an AC Stark shift.
But by understanding the
AC Stark shift or AC Stark
broadening which
comes along with that,
you can maybe map out
the interaction potential
between two atoms.
So people were really
ingenious in trying
to learn something about
atomic interactions
from spectroscopic
information, and that
was one of the few
tools they had.
Other questions?
OK.
We have covered the
simple examples.
And now I want to give you a
more comprehensive framework
called perturbation theory
of spectral broadening.
And in the last class, I
mentioned to you already
that, by using
this framework, we
can more deeply understand
line broadening mechanisms.
And one highlight actually
will be that next week,
using these concepts, we
will actually understand that
collisions cannot only cause
collisional broadening,
they can also cause
collisional narrowing.
So some things which
are counterintuitive
have a very clear description
using this method.
So I think what I'm able to do
in the remaining 20 minutes is
to step you through
the derivation.
And then we apply it to a
number of interesting physical
situations next week.
Now, in a way, I
have to apologize
that what I present to you is
time dependent perturbation
theory again.
And again with a slightly
different notation, so
I think I go rather quickly for
the part which is just review.
But repeating something
is also a good thing.
But then I will
tell you when we go
beyond what we have
discussed and beyond what you
may have seen in textbooks.
So in other words, we do time
dependent perturbation theory.
We have a wave function which
is in two states, A and B.
And there's a time dependent
perturbation v. Schrodinger's
equation tells us that it's
probably the interaction
picture, that the rate of
change of the amplitude B
comes because we
start in the state A
and the perturbation
couples from state A to B.
And so we can solve it.
At this point, it's not even
perturbative, it's general.
And we are interested
in spectroscopy
in the rate of a transition,
because we do spectroscopy
and we measure what is the
population in the excited
state.
Because there was
a rate at which
atoms were transferred from
the calm to the excited state.
So the rate is the
probability to be
in the excited
state per unit time.
So what we are interested now
is, what is the amplitude B?
And what is the
probability B squared
to be in the excited state?
And now comes
perturbation theory.
If we take
Schrodinger's equation
and we integrate it with respect
to time-- so we go from B dot
to B-- we are integrating
here with respect to time.
And in first-order
perturbation theory,
we assume the initial
state is undepleted.
And we replace the amplitude
A of t by its value at time t
equals 0, which is
assumed to be unity.
OK.
So with that-- oh yeah,
and this may be something.
I'm not doing anything which
goes beyond perturbation
theory, but I'm using a
slightly different formulation.
Because you will see that
I need it in a moment.
The rate is dB squared dt.
And if I take the
derivative of B squared,
I get B or B star times B dot.
So now I'm using
the perturbative--
I'm inserting this function
B into this expression
for the rate.
And this is what I obtain.
So I can take the
time derivative of it,
but the time derivative is only
affecting the upper integral.
So therefore what I get
is B is the integral.
B dot is the integrand.
And now I get this
expression, which
has the product of the
two matrix elements.
Simple mathematics,
plug and play.
No new concept.
But what it leads us now is,
and this is what is usually
not so much emphasized
in perturbation
theory, that everything
which happens to the atom,
and this is the rate at
which we excite the atom,
is now involving a
correlation function.
It involves sort of an
integral over the drive field v
at time t and time t prime.
And this is the
important concept
when you want to
explain and understand
line broadening and such.
You are driving the system
with an external field.
And often in
perturbation theory,
you assume the external field
is just e to the i omega t,
and this correlation function
is just e to the i omega t.
And it's so trivial that you
don't even recognize that e
to the i omega t is not the
time dependence of your field.
e to the i omega t is sort of
the product of the field at t
equals 0 and the field at time
t and the field at time t prime.
But if you have a more
general field with lots
of Fourier components, the
difference between whether it's
a correlation function or the
field itself becomes important.
In other words,
I'm now telling you
whenever you did perturbation
theory, this is what you did.
Maybe you didn't notice it,
but what you had was actually
the correlation function
between the drive field
at two different
times, t and t prime.
OK, so our rate is now given
by the correlation function
of the field.
And then we so-to-speak
Fourier transform it
with e to the i omega 0.
OK.
Let's just streamline
the expressions,
make them look nicer.
We integrate between
time 0 and t.
But let's now assume--
which is actually
the situation for many
fields of interest--
that the field is invariant
against translation in time t.
So therefore this
correlation function
does not depend on two times.
It only depends on the
time difference tau.
Finally, because of the complex
character of the Schrodinger
equation, I had an
expression but I
had to add the
complex conjugate.
Remember, the rate was the
derivative of B square.
And the derivative of B
square is B star B dot
times B star dot times B.
You get two terms.
And this is carried forward
with the complex conjugate.
But if the correlation
function has the proper t,
that complex conjugation means
you can go to negative time.
e to the i omega t
complex conjugate
is e to the minus i omega t.
That means now that we can
absorb the complex conjugate
by integrating not
from 0 to t, but having
the integral from
minus t to plus t.
And this will be the next
step for most situations
of interest.
This correlation, if you
drive it with the field,
the field has a
finite coherence time.
So therefore this
integral will not
have any contribution
when the times are
longer than the coherence time.
And then we can set minus
t and plus t to infinity.
So that will be our
final expression
which we will use to discuss
line broadening and line
shifts.
But we are not yet there.
We need-- so far, I've just done
ordinary perturbation theory.
The one extra thing
is I'm stressing
that when we have
a product of-- when
we had a matrix element
squared in perturbation theory,
this is really a correlation
function between the
[? external, ?] the drive
field at two different times.
We come back to that when
I discuss the result.
But the second thing I
want to introduce now
is that this framework,
which I have formulated,
allows me now to
include the fact
that different
atoms in my ensemble
may experience a
different drive field.
For instance, I gave you
the example in last class,
if you have Doppler
broadening, you
have atoms which start
out at the same point.
But the faster ones move faster
and experience the laser field
now with a different phase.
So different atoms
now experience
the perturbation v
in a different way.
So what I've done here so far
is I've pretty much written down
Schrodinger's equation
for a single particle.
But now we have to do
an ensemble average.
So therefore I introduce
now an ensemble average
by just taking that
expression and averaging
over all atoms in the ensemble.
So then I get the
ensemble averaged rate.
All the correlation
functions we discussed,
our ensemble averaged
correlation functions
and our final result will
also have an ensemble average.
OK.
So this correlation function
between v of 0 and v of t
will go to 0 for
very long times.
Even the most expensive laser
in the world, the electric field
which is emitted
now is not related
to the electric field which
is emitted in an hour.
Because the phase
relationship has been lost,
and therefore the correlation
function has decayed to 0.
OK.
So this is the ensemble average.
So therefore, what I'm
naturally drawn to now
is that if I take this
correlation function,
and I know any
correlation function has
a characteristic time called the
coherence time where it decays.
And therefore I can now
discuss two limiting cases.
One is where the time
evolution of the system
is started for times much
shorter than the coherence time
or much longer than
the coherence time.
And if what I'm
telling you right now
reminds you of my discussion of
Rabi oscillation versus Fermi's
golden rule-- yes,
this is actually
a very analogous discussion.
OK, so there are the
two limiting cases.
If the time is much shorter
than the coherence time-- let
me give you the example of an
oscillating single mode field.
The perturbation v of
t is just oscillating
with one frequency, omega.
And that means if I look
at the correlation function
at time t and time
t plus tau, it
is simply the
amplitude of the field
squared times e
to the i omega t.
And now I can take this
correlation function;
put it into my
integral, which has just
disappeared from the screen;
do the integration with e
to the i omega 0 t.
And this is the result I obtain.
And of course, this
is nothing else
than what you have
always obtained
in time dependent perturbation
theory with a sinusoidal field.
It is this characteristic
sine detuning
t over detuning,
which in the limit
and in the limit of when
you square it and go
to the limit of long times, it
turns into a delta function.
This gives us
Fermi's golden rule.
And of course, it has the
same behavior at short times.
At short times, the
probability for the atom
to be in the excited
state is quadratic.
Quadratic is like an
incipient Rabi oscillation.
And in perturbation theory,
we never get higher up.
We just look at the
beginning Rabi oscillation.
So therefore, the
probability is quadratic.
But I'm talking about
the rate, and the rate
is probability divided by time.
So that means the rate is
linearly increasing in time.
So I'm just saying this is
nothing else than rewriting
the physics of
Rabi oscillations.
OK.
If the time is longer
than the coherence time,
then we integrate the integral,
not from minus t to plus t.
We can take the
limits to infinity.
And that means we
obtain a result
which is now
independent of time.
And that means since
Wba is the rate,
we retrieve a constant
rate, and this
is what we have done
in Fermi's golden rule.
So therefore, when we
look at the time evolution
of a system driven by an
external field, the moment
we look for the time evolution
longer than the coherence
time-- and this is
where the main interest
is in spectroscopy-- we
have a Fermi's golden rule
result that the system is
excited at a constant rate.
And I want to now
reinterpret this rate.
This rate is nothing else
than the Fourier transform
of a correlation function.
It makes a lot of sense.
You apply time-dependent
magnetic fields, perturbations,
fluctuating magnetic fields,
whatever, vibration and noise
in your lab.
You just apply that to
the atom, and the atom
is nothing else than a
little Fourier analyzer.
It says, my resonance
frequency is omega 0.
And all of what matters for
me to make a real transition
is what you offer me at omega 0.
And I now Fourier
analyze whatever
acts on me, the correlation
function of the perturbation
which acts on me, and
I fully analyze it.
And what matters for my rate
to go to the excited state
is the Fourier component
at the resonance frequency.
It's just a
generalization of what
we have done in
perturbation theory
when we assumed that we
have a drive field only
at one frequency.
So I've written it
down here for you.
The rate of excitation
is nothing else
than the Fourier transform
of this correlation function.
But let me now take
it one step further,
which also makes a lot of sense.
The Fourier transform
of the correlation
function-- the
correlation function
is the convolution of
the time-dependent fields
with themselves, v of
t with v of t plus tau.
The Fourier transform
of the convolution
is the product of the Fourier
transform of the field itself.
So therefore, I
can take whatever
perturbation the atom
experiences in its own frame--
external fields, moving around.
Whatever the atom
is exposed to, I
have to calculate
the power spectrum
of what the atom feels.
And this power spectrum
provides me the excitation rate.
It's nothing else than
Fermi's golden rule
but generalized to the
concept of an arbitrary
spectrum of the driving field.
Questions so far?
You can also say
that's a wonderful way
to look at energy conservation.
If an atom is exposed to
any kind of environment,
it goes from the ground
to the excited state only
to the extent that whatever
acts on the atom has a Fourier
component at the
resonance frequency.
And it is only the power
of the fluctuating drive
field at the resonance
frequency which
is responsible for
driving the atom.
And this is energy conservation.
The frequency component
has to be omega 0
to take the atom from the
calm to the excited state.
All the other
frequency components
take the atom to the virtual
state and take it down again.
They create maybe line shifts
or something like this.
But a real transition,
a transition
where the atom stays
in the excited state,
requires photons at the
resonance frequency.
And so to speak, this
measures how many
photons are acting on the atoms.
Let me now give you one
or two general features
of such correlation
functions which I just
find very, very useful.
And then I think
your time is over.
If we have G of w
is now the spectrum
of the fluctuating fields.
And let's assume,
yes, eventually we
have a fluctuating
field which is somewhere
centered at the
resonance frequency.
After all, we use a
laser, but the atom
may now move around
in the laser beam.
The mirrors may be vibrating.
So the spectrum seen
by the atom is sort of
broadened around the
resonance frequency.
And the broadening is
nothing else than 1
over the coherence time
of the environment.
So let me just normalize
the correlation function
that the integral is unity.
And then this is
trivial but important.
The value at the
resonance frequency
is 1 over the broadening and is
therefore the coherence time.
It's sort of subtle
but important.
If you have a
normalized spectrum,
the more coherent
your source is,
the larger is the value
of the correlation
function in the center.
Let me do the Fourier transform.
If you Fourier transform
something like this,
it gives an oscillating function
at the resonance frequency.
But let me just multiply by
e to the i omega t and sort
of shift everything
to 0 frequency,
then we would find that
the temporal correlation
function decays.
And it decays over
characteristic time tau
coherence, which is nothing
else than the inverse line
bits of the Fourier transform.
This has nothing to do
with atomic physics.
It's just properties of the
function is Fourier transform.
But now we have the situation.
Our rate was the temporal
correlation function times e
to the i omega 0 t.
The integrand here is exactly
what I'm plotting here.
And so if I perform
the integration,
at least without getting
the last numerical factor,
I can approach the result by the
correlation function at time t
equals 0 times-- if I
do the integration--
times the temporal
rates of this curve,
so this is the
correlation time tau c.
So therefore, if I have,
for instance, my operator
is the electric
field and I drive
the atom with a
dipole operator, what
I find is the
correlation function at t
equals 0 is nothing else than
the electric field squared,
which is what we have called the
Rabi frequency squared so far.
But now I multiply it
with a coherence time.
So this result should
come very naturally to you
because when we have
Fermi's golden rule,
we have a matrix element squared
times the delta function.
But I've emphasized it again
and again-- the delta function
is representative for spectral
widths for density of states.
And if we have an
environment which
causes spectral broadening,
1 over the coherence time
is nothing else than the
spectral widths here.
And so I've done here exactly
what the delta function
Fermi's golden rule
asked me to do.
So if I had wanted, I
could have just said,
look, here is
Fermi's golden rule.
And by interpreting Fermi's
golden rule the way I just did,
I could have written down this
result for you right away.
OK, I think time is over.
And maybe the
summary which I could
give you now is a
good starting point
for our lecture on Monday.
Reminder, Friday we have the
midterm in this other lecture
hall in the other building.
We start at the
normal class time.
Please be there on time.